[Música]
muy buenos días hoy se abre un nuevo
capítulo en esta larga lucha legal para
que assange no sea extraditado a eeuu
donde de ser encontrado culpable podría
enfrentar una prisión de hasta 175 años
desde muy temprana hora ha habido un
gran movimiento aquí donde nos
encontramos en el tribunal del old
bailey a unas cuadras de la catedral de
san pablo hace unos minutos salió del
tribunal el padre de julian assange john
shipton que nos dijo que no ha podido
ver a su hijo no sabe en qué estado de
salud mental y psicológico se encuentra
también confirmó que sus abogados
defensores han tenido acceso limitado a
su cliente y que la última vez que lo
vieron fue hace seis meses así que
inicia este juicio en medio de una gran
expectativa de la prensa internacional y
con un grupo de simpatizantes que desde
muy temprana hora se han dado cita aquí
en las afueras del baile
con una sola consigna liberen a julian
assange entonces a usted marcela por la
información